if you look at like the instagram
channel nature's metal
it hurts my heart to watch to remind
me a comfortable descendant of ape
how vicious nature is just
unapologetically uh
just i mean there's a there's a process
to it
where the bad guy always wins
the the violence
is the solution to most problems or
the flip side of that running away from
violence is the solution depending on
your skill set
and it's funny to think of us humans
with our extra little
piece of brain that we're somehow trying
to figure out
like you said in the philosophical way
how to supersede that how to like move
past the viciousness the cruelty
the just the cold
exchange of nature but perhaps it's not
so
maybe that is nature maybe that's the
way of life maybe we're trying too hard
to uh we're being too
egotistical and thinking we're somehow
separate from nature we're somehow
distant from that very thing
i couldn't agree with him more in fact i
think actually orson scott card you know
was the writer of a great book called
anders game
um was this was a statement that that
the main character
you know ender uh made in the book his
brother was
brilliant um his brother was like kind
of sociopathic brilliant kid
that was ended up kicked out of the
school that they were all into for
battle commander
dealing with his brother taught him that
ultimately strength courage
the ability to do violence for all the
good and the bad of that is
one of the fundamental most important
things to be able to do in life because
if you can't cause destruction if you
can't cause pain
you will be forever subject to those who
can and i think that you mentioned
egotism i think that that's a disease
that could
obviously strike any of us but it's
something that we're looking at now
we're
you know i think we should be
unbelievably thankful as people that
live
in the world that we do um that we can
walk down the street without having to
worry that i'm like well don't worry
that that six foot six 270 pound person
over there
is just gonna leave me alone and i have
a rolex on but whatever
i'll be fine because that person's
deciding to leave me alone because we've
all agreed to live in this relatively
you know sane and or you know
constrained society because it benefits
all of us and we're doing it because of
a philosophical underpinning
not because nature dictates it be that
way because nature dictates it go in a
very very different direction and the
only person the only thing stopping that
person from doing
something to me is either me that person
or someone else that will stand in
between us and if i can't do it
and there's no one there to stand in
between us then the only thing stopping
that person is that person and i have to
hope that they're uh
either disinterested or disinclined to
do that sort of thing and i think that
uh
you know it's keeping in mind that that
that is the fundamental
nature of the world whether we like it
or not um
is important and i think the the quest
to fundamentally alter human nature is
going to be ultimately fruitless and
then also it's
it is a little bit egotistical the lion
does what a lion does
you know we we can try to box it in and
we can try to you know
guide this direction that direction but
you know
nature is as it is and as it always will
be unless we want to start to
constrain it significantly but now i'm
starting to get into individual rights
who put me in charge who says that i
should be the one to make the choice is
constraining because many of the most
awful things that have happened
throughout history one group or one
person has decided to constrain others
and we don't like genghis khan doing
that well i'll do that on a little level
are there going to be beneficial
benefits and beneficiaries absolutely
but
they'll be losers in that too so i guess
it's a it's a dangerous game it's almost
like putting on the one ring you know we
remember when frodo offered the one ring
to gandalf
and gandalf said no no i would take it
away i would put it on
i would use it out of the desire to do
good but through me it would wield the
power so terrible you can't imagine
i think that's that's the big question
for anyone that decides
that's able to have reach and able to
have power
i mean obviously i can't speak to that
but imagine you did have
national level global level power how
would you use
it would you try to change the world
would you be glad that you did down the
line
i don't know
you